The previous problem brings up a useful little formula from topology called the
Euler-PoincarÊ Formula for connected planar graphs. V is the number of
vertices. F is the number of faces. E is the number of edges, and g is the
genus. The genus is the number of holes in the object. As an example, a sphere
and a cube have genus zero. A doughnut and a coffee cup with a handle have
genus one. There's an old joke about topologists not being able to tell their
coffee cup from their donut. An edge collapse is a reversible process, so let's
show how it affects the formula. First we know we're going to have a vertex
created, so that's one. We can see that as the point moves up, two faces are
created, so that's two faces. We can also see three edges are created. The
genus doesn't change. There are no holes created or destroying. We can see this
sums up to zero, the delta. In other words, this formula applies to this mesh
and this mesh, and they both must come out to be the answer too, so the delta
must be zero, the difference between them. So this equation says we subtracted
a vertex in two faces. To balance the equation, 3 edges must also be removed.